THEMSELVES.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> SURE.
>> Tucker: LAURA INGRAHAM
HOSTS "INGRAHAM ANGLE" IS HERE
AND A FRIEND AND GRATE TO FEEL
HAVE HER IN THE STUDIO --
GRATEFUL TO HAVE HER IN THE
STUDIO TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
A BIG MEDIA ANGLE TO THIS.
THE PRESS DROVE A LOT OF THIS
BEHAVIOR AND DROVE THE
INVESTIGATION.
AT FOX, WE ARE ALLOWED TO SAY
BY THE NETWORK WHATEVER WE
THINK IS TRUE.
THEY SUPPORT US COMPLETELY IN
THAT.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR IT.
IF YOU WATCH THE OTHER
COVERAGE REALLY THEY ARE
READING EVERY HOUR FROM THE
SAME -- MADDOW CLEARLY SAYS
WHAT SHE WANTS BUT EVERYONE
ELSE SEEMS SO READ FROM A
SCRIPT THAT JEFFSUCKER WROTE.
HOW -- JEFF ZUCER WROTE.
>> I THINK THE COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE MEDIA, THE D.N.C.,
THE DEEP STATE IS PROFOUND.
AND THE INTERNATIONAL ELITE
WHO WANTS THIS TO BE TRUE.
THERE IS AN INTERNATIONAL
ANGLE HERE.
WE LOOK AT THE UKRAINE ANGLE
THERE.
SAN INTERNATIONAL ANGLE HERE.
TRUMP CAME ALONG AND HE WAS
CAN GREAT DISRUPTOR ON THE
SCENE.
I DON'T BUY INTO WHAT YOU ARE
DOING FOR THE E.U. AND YOUR
CONFABS AND YOUR WINE SELLERS
AND THE THINK TANK.
THE INDUSTRY EMPLOYS THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE.
TRUMP SAID THIS IS NOT WORKING
WELL.
HE WAS AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT
TO THEM.
THEY SHELL OUT THE MONEY FOR
PEOPLE LIKE JOHN MEACHAM -- I
LIKE HIM, HE IS A TALENTED
WRITER.
BUT IF SOMEONE LIKE JOHN
MEACHAM WAS CAUGHT UP IN THIS
AT MSNBC.
I LOOKED AT THIS.
HE SAID THIS IS THE TESTIFY IN
ADDITION OF TREASON.
AND HE IS A HISTORIAN.
HE IS A PULITZER PRIZE WINNING
WRITER.
IF SOMEONE LIKE THAT CAN GET
CAUGHT AND ENSNARED IN THIS
FROTHY FRENZY TO GET TRUMP, WE
HAVE A BIG PROBLEM ON OUR
HANDS.
I'M SO GLAD.
I WATCHED EVERY MINUTE OF YOUR
SHOW TONIGHT, TUCKER.
AS I DO EVERY NIGHT.
BUT WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
NEED FOR CONSEQUENCES AND
REPERCUSSIONS IS JUST LIKE
THINGS LIKE JUSSIE SMOLLETT OR
UVA RAPE CASE OR WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE CALVING -- KAVANAUGH
LEAKSES.
EITHER THE PUBLIC SHOULD WATCH
SOMETHING ELSE OR THERE NEEDS
TO BE A AN INVESTIGATION BY
BILL BARR HOW IT WENT DOWN.
THE FISA WARRANT AND THE LEAKS
THAT HAPPEN.
ALL THIS STUFF HAS TO BE
LOOKED AT.
THIS CANNOT HAPPEN TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
DEMOCRAT OR A REPUBLICAN.
>> I DON'T CARE WHO YOU ARE.
THE CRIMINALIZATION OF
POLITICS BROUGHT DOWN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CAUGHT UP
IN THE GEARS AND THE MACHINERY
OF THE PROSECUTION COMPLEX IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: THAT IS LITERALLY
TRUE.
PEOPLE CALL FOR MY FIRING
EVERY DAY.
>> DITTO.
>> Tucker: YOURS, TOO.
>> BUT THINK MORE SLOWLY ABOUT
THE ISSUES.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
I JUST WONDER -- I'M GRATEFUL
TO WORK HERE.
I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN.
I WONDER HOW CAN JEFF ZUCKER
RUN THE CHANNEL AFTER WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
THEY ARE CLEARLY GETTING
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS
INVESTIGATION, AND THEY PUT IT
ON THE AIR AS PROPAGANDA AND
IT TURNED OUT TO BE LIES.
HOW CAN YOU DO THAT?
>> ALL THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
BUDDHIST SAID THE FINGERS
POINT BACK AT YOU.
SO EVERYTHING THEY SAY AT
TRUMP, STATE RUN TV.
COLLUDING.
COLLUDING AND THE STATE RUN
TV, THEY ARE WORKING FOR THE
DEEP STATE OR ELITE STATE OR
WHATEVER YOU CALL IT.
THEY ARE COLLUDING AND TRUMP
IS LIKE WAIT A SECOND I'M JUST
A GUY FROM NEW YORK.
I CAME IN AND I WANT TO MAKE
THIS COUNTRY BETTER.
I'M LIKE MY OWN MAN AND I KNOW
I'M GOING TO TICK YOU OFF BUT
I WANT AMERICA TO THRIVE AND
BE PROSPEROUS.
REALLY WELL THOUGHT OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE SMART PEOPLE ARE
THROWING THE WORD "TREASON,"
"TRAITOR."
THE GUY SHOULD BE IN HANDCUFFS
AND LED FROM THE OVAL
OFFICE --
ALL THESE PEOPLE SHOULD LOOK
IN THE MIRROR AND SAY MAYBE I
NEED TO RE-EXAMINE HOW I SPEAK
ON THE ISSUE IN THE FUTURE.
NOT THAT WE DON'T ALL MAKE
MISTAKES.
WE DO.
I DO, YOU DO.
>> Tucker: I MADE BIG
MISTAKES.
>> AS DO I.
THESE WERE PRONOUNCEMENTS THAT
WOULD DESTROY FAMILIES,
DESTROY PRESIDENCIES.
AND AS YOU POINTED OUT
EARLY -- I'M SO GLAD YOU
DID -- THE LOST OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE ACTUALLY
WORKED WITH COUNTRIES THAT
COULD BOX OUT CHINA ON THINGS.
YOU MEAN DO WE REALLY NOT WANT
TO WORK WITH RUSSIA ON
ANYTHING EVER AGAIN?
LAST TIME I CHECKED, CHINA HAS
THE BIGGEST THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY IS THE SIZE
OF FRANCE'S.
>> Tucker: TEXAS.
>> C'MON!
NOW RUSSIA AND CHINA ARE DOING
MILITARY EXERCISES AND WE ARE
ON SIDELINE GOING OKAY, WE
HAVE TO ACT REALLY MEAN ON
EVERYTHING WITH RUSSIA BECAUSE
OF THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
IT HAD A PROFOUND POLICY
EFFECT I THINK ON THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> AND WE WILL NEVER KNOW
REALLY THE EFFECT ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE
GEOPOLITICAL POSITION.
THAT MUST BE EXAMINED.
>> Tucker: ON THE SOCIAL
FABRIC.
YOU HAVE NOTICE OUT HERE LIKE
YOU, I AM NOT FROM WASHINGTON
BUT I SPENT MOST OF MY LIFE
HERE.
YOU, TOO.
I HAVE KNOWN YOU FOR MOST OF
THE TIME.
THIS CITY BECOME PARANOID,
DISTRUSTFUL, ANGRY.
I TALK TO PEOPLE ALL THE TOMB.
I CAN'T TEXT THAT TO YOU.
I DON'T TRUST MY TEXT.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
WHAT COUNTRY IS THIS?
I CAN'T HAVE THE INFORMATION,
I'M TOO NERVOUS?
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID.
DO YOU WANT TO LIVE IN A PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE ARE AFRAID?
>> IT'S A PROSECUTION STATE
BECOMES SO BIG AND SO
POWERFUL, A MERE ACCUSATION
CAN TURN YOUR LIFE UPSIDE
DOWN.
>> Tucker: YES!
>> TRUMP HAS MONEY AND HE CAN
DEFEND HIMSELF.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> HE HAPPENED TO BE INNOCENT
OF THESE CHARGES.
HE KNEW IT ALL ALONG.
EVERYONE WHO SAID, HE IS, WHY
IS HE MEETING BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS WITH THE RUSSIANS?
WHY DID HE VLADIMIR PUTIN DASH
WHATEVER THE CRITICISMSH --
WHATEVER THE CRITICISM.
MAYBE HE KNEW TO LOOK PAST
MUELLER AND DO THE RIGHT THING
AT THE MOMENT FOR THE COUNTRY.
THEY NEVER GIVE HIM THAT
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
HE DESERVED IT AND HE NEVER
GOT IT FROM THEM.
>> Tucker: WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT?
>> I THINK THE LEFT IS GOING
TO GO INTO A DEEPER RAGE.
I THINK THEY WILL LEARN
NOTHING FROM THIS SADLY.
MAYBE SOME OF THE SMARTER
FOLKS LIKE MEACHAM AND OTHERS
WILL.
BUT I THINK NOW IT WILL TURN
TO -- IT'S NOT TRANSPARENT.
BARR WAS BROUGHT IN TO BE THE
CLEAN-UP MAN HERE.
THIS ISN'T A SERIOUS REVIEW.
LIKE WE SEE ON THE SOCIALISM
LURCH, LEANING OR SLOUCHING TO
SOCIALISM IN THIS CASE THEY
WILL BE IN A PRECARIOUS
POSITION WITH THE INTERIM
ANGER -- INTERNAL ANGER SAYING
WE FINALLY GOT THE ROAD
RUNNER.
WILY COYOTE.
LIKE THE ACME T.N.T.
BEEP, BEEP!
HE IS GONE AGAIN.
I THINK THEY WILL FREAK.
I DON'T THINK MUCH WILL
CHANGE.
BUT IT WILL MEAN THEY WILL
MOVE MORE RADICAL ON THE
POLICY FRONT AND TRY TO WHIP
UP MORE ENTHUSIASM THAT WAY.
YOU DON'T SEE WHAT ELSE THEY
DO.
TO PUT THE HOPE IN THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT.
GOING BACK TO THAT?
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW
YORK?
>> Tucker: FRO GUESSK --
PROGRESSKLY POLITICIZED.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: WHO IS ON YOUR
SHOW?
>> KEN STARR AND U. COUNSEL